Magnus you started the day three points
Behind The Duda now you're only half a
point behind do that and you're actually
surprised by that yeah I mean I didn't I
I made like a conscious effort not to
look at the standings all day partly
because it's nicer to look at it when
you're when you're when you're doing
well but um yeah obviously now it's um
anyone's game you started off slowly you
lost the game but after that you just
started you won five in a row basically
what changed at that point
to be honest like I didn't feel so good
today uh I I mean I stayed up to to
watch the Miami Boston game I I yeah I
mean I was going to go to sleep but then
the game was
exciting and then but the problem was I
couldn't sleep so well earlier today so
yeah I didn't feel feel great and to be
honest like the amount of luck I had
a turning point actually yeah yeah no
it's just
for each of those five games to all end
in wins like so many things had to go go
right but I'll take it of course of
course and let's talk about this last
game because
you definitely came out with an
aggressive stance yeah okay but this was
yeah this was an insane moment like uh
why on Earth did I not go Knight A5
that's what I realized like right right
after because I was thinking that the
pawn was hanging but after she knighted
I was thinking that I need to go Bishop
D4 first uh Bishop D7 first down then uh
uh but anyway I mean so many things
happened and was the strategical point
behind the Knight A5 just yeah I just
want to climb down on the on the queen
side and then as long as white doesn't
have like Italian chances on
um on the king side you have a space
advantage and uh and a bishop pair so
the long-term prospects are are pretty
pretty nice and you are out playing him
but then yeah a little bit wild yeah
uh wouldn't you feel like you're losing
uh oh no I was losing control here
because I mean I could tell
I could tell that my position is
probably winning uh but I had no idea
what to do
um you had two minutes and he had only
13 seconds so yeah uh but but here like
up to this point at least for a while
like all of my moves have been
completely automatic and now I actually
have to think and I failed
uh spectacular
all right let's see G5 G4S yeah like
ideas like rookie eight then Knight C2
Bishop D5 I didn't think about it at all
like just to hold okay yeah but here I I
knew that this F4 stuff was crazy but I
I just didn't I just didn't see what to
do at this point no at this point but
this whole plan yeah was was insane yeah
um you guys got to descend game yeah I'm
probably not probably not worse but I'm
not really better either oh for a second
you thought that you might even be worse
yeah like a little bit before but now
yeah
um
I mean basically we just got to this
kind
of
um position and like once I get this H
Pawn with seconds I think I'm
considerably considerably more likely to
win than he is to
uh to make a draw because I can just
move around forever uh and it's really
funny that we're just playing on
opposite color complexes and nothing's
really you know vulnerable but
eventually I I figured I should be able
to get to get the king and get the yeah
Magnus congratulations huge day for you
yeah I should say one thing now
um so I did play the so
um first of all huge congratulations to
uh my good friend and Coach uh Peter uh
who has his 50th um birthday uh today
um so I asked him yesterday if you had
any wishes and His Wish was that I
played the Danish Gambit and that's what
I tried to do against Lavon
yeah so I'm sure he'll be um be be happy
about that and also he is not here with
you because of his fifth year
anniversary right
um yeah also like he usually doesn't
come to the
that's normal what are you going to do
tonight in preparation for tomorrow
to play some football with um
the P player so it could be fun that
should be fun yeah Magnus thank you very
much we'll see you tomorrow thank you
guys back to you